[Music]
i'm hesitant to bring something up
because i don't know what this means but
it's looking like my newborn daughter
conan might have red hair
is it true really it looks like it yeah
you know the hair can change for
newborns but the the first fluff fell
out and then the stuff coming in is kind
of
red
i need your guidance what do i do
uh you gotta give her up no you do not
have to give her up
sona oh i'm sorry i thought that's where
we were all headed no no that's not
where we're headed do i put her in a
program is there some kind of therapy
what do i do well you should know some
things there are some things that make
uh i've mentioned this before but i was
the only redhead of six kids in my
family and uh i remember thinking
that it bestowed some sort of i don't
know it was like a magical mystical sign
that i was
meant for greatness
and then we realized that wasn't true
but uh
but then i got into the show business
and sort of hacked out a living
but no it is uh everything you've heard
is true um there are fewer and fewer
redheads all the time we will go extinct
it's a squirrely jean
which means
you can have 50 kids and none of them
will be redheads and then someone else
can have
two kids and both of them are redheads
and the parents don't even have red hair
so it's a gene that just shows up places
so you don't know but i think it means
that your daughter is destined to do
amazing things i really do okay i like
the sound of that and when i say amazing
things i mean wear a large hat at the
take a beach time to find someone who
will
date you
oh no does she have very fair skin yeah
yeah she does amanda's got kind of more
olive tone skin where i have you know
the irish pink as well and i think she
got that and i have a little red
um in family history and my beard used
to be red oh i thought you meant you had
a little red on your body like your
whole body is not redheaded but then
there's a small tuft at your lower back
he's got that little copper brillo pad
in his low back what is it happening i
don't know
no i used to have a kind of reddish
beard but now it's mostly gray yeah it's
not too early to dye her hair
and no don't this is terrible it is too
early it's not too early what's wrong
with being a redhead ask think of all
the great redheads in history
oh whoo
little orphan annie
pippi longstocking
fictional character the wendy's girl no
way i auditioned to be the wendy's girl
and i came in third carrot top carrot
top this yeah i gotta dye her hair yeah
you gotta get you gotta fix that
situation no no
you gotta fix it when it's but it's
early
no it's this isn't like this isn't like
she has bowed legs and needs to get
braces
this is red hair it's it's beautiful
beautiful i mean
i can't see
they put those little rubber helmets to
fix how their plates are coming together
we need to get a little like helmet that
injects just a little bit of dye over
time give her little option she'll never
know she was a redhead yeah guys do you
know how many times in my 20s women came
up to me and said oh my god a redhead i
want to do you
how many times zero
[Laughter]
it was a trick question no one ever said
that uh um oh my god i want to do you
does that not how people talk it's not
happy even if you had brown hair nobody
would say that to you i mean yeah girl
woman talk to a guy like i've never gone
up to a guy i've been like yeah i
wouldn't do you
sona i beg to differ i remember you
you had a little crazy time there in
your mid-20s that i was witness too okay
did you not act that way sometimes
moving on i would never go up to a guy
that
yeah i had i had game it was different
yeah your game was you'd hit them over
the head with a club
and then drag them to your room that's
what you did it was caveman style
anyway you gotta dye her hair did you
have game did you have a game back in
the day sona do you have game yes i had
you saw me i believe it you saw me you
saw me when i would like you know talk
to guys
flirted up i was sorry i remember
sitting
when you were single and there'd be a
waiter that would come over who you
thought was cute and you'd make these
big eyes at the waiter i remember that
very clearly i've left my number on
checks before
at restaurants yeah i've done that
you've done that at pawn shops
[Laughter]
real funny that's funny
anyway dye her hair matt
an old man who just he just left a
crutch a cane there
i pawned it you pondered your
grandfather's cane
i was like well thank you very much
what's this number well
once you call it and find out
first date i brought you a transistor
radius
it's got bakelite dials it's from the
40s
i hate it here do you really you're in
your own home yeah um
okay well listen we'll get back on track
and just say that i'm i'm very happy for
you that she's a redhead and i think uh
i've
of course seen her she's beautiful
and i think she's gonna represent
us redheads perfectly and uh she'll be a
great member of our tribe and i hope her
hair never changes i hope it's just just
fiery red for her entire life
okay i curse you